and let me tell you something my sources
here tell
tell me and i didn't really want to say
this
but they used to look at jimmy g a
little sideways like he was kind of a
little bit mr glass and i'm not talking
about the sam jackson character
right where they were they were like
can't really depend on him
can't stay on the field what are we
talking about here i ain't gonna say no
names
players players are coaches how about
how about it but let's talk about
initials
just let's just say they were between
the lines
that were between the lines yeah people
that are still here are now gone oh
let's just say they were between the
lines they were between the lines why
did you just do a report where
were they who was it between the lines
so his teammates thought he was soft
just let me i'm not saying who i'm just
saying between the lines they live in
the line
they looked at him a little bit like can
we really count on this dude
that's jermaine wiggins part of the greg
hill show on w-e-e-i
talking about patriots players
presumably since they are the ones
between the lines
who had concerns about the reliability
of jimmy garoppolo this narrative of him
not being available isn't new chris 2006
four-game suspension for tom brady for
deflategate jimmy garoppolo's audition
for the nfl
what happens he gets injured in the
second game with a shorter problem
jacoby brissett gets a chance
to audition for the remaining two games
of the four-game suspension so
i'm not shocked by this no and it makes
you wonder
is there a sense of of
caution as it relates to the possibility
of bringing back jimmy garoppolo and i i
they got cam newton i i to me i don't
see it i know people like tom curran
think it's possible
but stories like that make me think it's
less possible yeah i mean
i'm not like i don't think it's totally
out of like crazyville
i think there may be still a possibility
but i'm with you i think it's
like less likely to happen than more
likely to happen
and i think that was a real thing to
what jermaine wiggins was talking about
you know as far as the the perception of
jimmy g
in new england i think there was real
disappointment
you know at the time in
one let's see so it was that second game
against the dolphins he gets hurt in the
first half of the game he's playing
really well
you know week three they play the
buffalo bills and that's where they did
some of the wildcat jacoby brissette
i think there was thought that he could
still play in that game
and then the week after that the fourth
game which he didn't play
i think there was a lot of guys that
thought wait he could play and do this
and whatever else and there i think it
was a little disappointment throughout
the organization
that that didn't happen so hey when you
have stuff like that
you know and of course all the things
that have gone on
on the field and him being injured and
all the time he's missed listen
perception becomes reality
and in this fact in this case it's not
perception the reality is the reality on
this one
and you do have to worry about this with
jimmy garoppolo as your starting
quarterback
you got to have a good backup because
you just can't trust them to stay
healthy for the whole year
we drafted yesterday the potential
destinations for jimmy garoppolo but i
think
any team out there that would be
considering him has to factor
that into their assessment because if
you do
trade for jimmy garoppolo or sign him in
the event that he would be cuddle i
think a trade is more likely with a
reworked contract
and he gets injured what are they going
to hear from us and everyone else
yeah right why did you trust this guy as
your starter he's missed 23
of 48 games over the past three years
you knew or should have known
that the guy has a propensity to not be
available
yeah agreed to me it has to
come with the territory with him you
know yeah okay we got jimmy g
he's going to be our starter all right
well we better have a guy that we know
we can depend on to be the backup
there's nothing and again he can he can
right this ship and hopefully he goes on
a run here where he doesn't get hurt for
seven
eight years in a row but right now yes
there's no way i would have him on my
team
without the first thought of going wait
he's here
who else are we going to have behind him
because the chances are that he is going
to miss a game or two during the
football season
and you know i get pushback from people
sometimes why do you hate jimmy
garoppolo i don't i don't hate him i
don't know him i don't have an opinion
about him personally
all i know is the guy's gotten paid a
ton of money
and one of the things you get paid for
as a professional athlete is to be
available
and if you consistently aren't available
at a time when you have
made and i'm doing the rough math here
let's just say a crapload of money
over the past three seasons there's a
point where tough questions are going to
be asked because
there are plenty of other guys out there
even at the quarterback position
nowadays plenty of guys who are capable
of doing the job and not doing something
stupid like lowering his shoulder
at the sideline and blowing out your acl
that for me that was the moment
and that's why i wonder what kyle
thought or said
when he realized what jimmy garoppolo
has done when when i
saw that and realized that that that
kind of
stupid in the moment inability to
control
that basic tough guy instinct mindset
whatever
and it and it tears his acl i mean i've
criticized other guys for doing that
don't why are you delivering a blow at
the sideline get your ass out of bounds
and live to see another play you owe
that to the team that's paying you all
that money and your teammates to be
available
that to me was when i said this guy i i
got doubts about this guy they're never
going to go away because
he's the only well i mean others have
done things that's stupid he's the only
one to tear an acl doing something
that's stupid yeah well it's it's just
uh you know a little other than bill
grammatica
who tore at acl celebrating jumping in
there was another guy
another guy tore at acl celebrating
other than that
other than that this is the stupidest
thing i've seen well it just goes into
the category of like
meat-headedness right i mean that's
really where it goes into and
and i think that's you know something
that
at times i think you and i have joked
about over the years so that's where he
comes off
comes off a little bit as different
maybe to other quarterbacks in the nfl
that way
you know maybe not necessarily always
the most cerebral
and the way he talks in front of the
podium and and all of that
um but yeah it it's it's it's a concern
it really is there's talent there as we
know
he can do a lot of good things on the
field he's in
you know unflappable in a lot of ways
too he always has the same demeanor
so all those things you're gonna like
about him playing quarterback
you know in the pocket he's pretty good
he can change his arm and do things like
that get the ball out of his hand in a
hurry
but that's the great risk of jimmy
garoppolo and that's where it's going to
be really interesting
to see who trades for him you know and
and
what they do give up for him if that all
comes about the 49ers finally do offer
them out there
and then of course what they do with the
rest of the quarterback room to support
him for the
in case situation that we're talking
about so with a meet-headedness rating
of 98 in madden jimmy garoppolo would be
a perfect candidate to be a quarterback
for the detroit lions frankly to tie it
back to something we talked about
earlier
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports